the United Nations is warning of massive
flooding in Mozambique that's after the
second giant storm in just six weeks
plowed into the southern African country
cyclone Kenneth made landfall late
Thursday and authorities say it's
aftermath could bring twice as much rain
as cyclone it I did just last month
disaster agencies say 700,000 people
could be at risk at least three people
have died since the storm struck we're
joined now by Matt Carter from the
International Federation of the Red
Cross he's in Nampula Mozambique Matt
tell us how are things looking now since
the cyclone made landfall and how are
the people coping yes it's early days
assessment team has still carrying out
work in the far north of Mozambique but
the first indications are there there
are some districts within that but far
more than most province that have had
severe damage I've read reports this
morning of one district losing 90% of
its homes many districts are without
power and as you say the forecast is for
a prolonged spell of heavy rains and we
you know we were really worried about
landslides and about flash flooding in
the short term Mozambique is still
recovering from cyclone it is the nation
in any way prepared for what's happening
and the heavy rains that are predicted
yeah I mean as you saying it's been
quite unprecedented the last six weeks
have two such large-scale storms in such
a short space of time is is unheard of
in this this area of the world the
international aid community have an
ongoing and large scale response in the
town of Barrow which is in the central
Mozambique about this hundred kilometers
south of the northernmost province
member being the cat's paw and so that's
a really better position this time to to
respond more quickly the bobeat Red
Cross had teams on the ground in the
days leading up to the cyclone
disseminating early warning messaging to
their communities and now is the safety
these that are on the ground carrying
out the assessments and feeding back to
us it's early days but we are getting a
picture of the scale of the damage and
what needs to be done what are their
most urgent priorities now what are what
are they focusing on I think in the
short term particularly for some
districts that have lost the large
proportion of their housing it's it's
providing tents it's food and water in
the short term well we're also worried
that standing water will inevitably give
rise to waterborne disease we saw an
outbreak of cholera in the weeks after
cyclone need a and we we fear this might
happen again in the north and manga term
the worry is it's harvest time here and
a lot of agricultural land my well a
feed damaged and for those subsistence
farmers the worry is what they're going
to be eating in the next three to six
months and for those working on the farm
where they're laid by B hoods have gone
so you know the Red Cross have a long
long present a long time present in
going anywhere
and we'll assess the situation and
respond as best we can
all right Matt Carter from the
International Federation of the Red
Cross thank you so much and good luck to
you